Congratulations on
finishing the first level.
You've learned a little
bit about game engines,
gaming platforms, how to break a game
down into its component parts, and
how LibGDX allows you to
write cross platform games.
Finally, you made sure you were
set up for success in this course.
Well, sorry for making you stare
at my face so much in this level.
That won't be a problem
in future levels,
since you'll actually be programming
instead of staring at me.
In the next level you'll set up your
tools, load up your first LibGDX project
and get your first game running on
your computer and on your phone.
The next two levels
are all about drawing.
You'll learn about the computer drawing
pipeline, draw some simple shapes, and
to spice things up a bit,
we'll also be drawing some fractals.
Level five is all about making those
shapes move around the screen.
We'll learn about the game loop and
we'll also set up some
cool fake physics.
In level six, we'll learn how to
handle user inputs including touches,
key presses and device orientation.
Level seven and eight will wrap
together everything you've learned so
far into the finished game.